Presenter: All right.
Hello, everyone,
and welcome again to
the @Google program.
This installment for musicians
at Google, as you can tell.
We're welcoming
today Eric Lewis,
renowned jazz pianist
and is only getting
hotter on the scene.
He was recently featured
at the April conference --
TED Conference,
uh, where he was, I think,
his first exposure
to a lot of the Bay Area,
or the Bay Area's
first exposure to Eric.
Uh, tore the house down,
left it wanting more.
And sure enough he came
back a couple of times.
He came back to the DNA lounge
doing a benefit concert,
uh, which he came back
again last night for
and, uh, once again,
just getting rave reviews
all over the place.
Uh, extremely pleased to
have him at Google and, uh,
if you could join me
in welcoming him.
[applause]
Presenter: Uh, so I just had
a couple of quick questions
before you dove into the piano
and we'll also give him a break
to talk a little bit more
in between some of his
some of his pieces.
But Eric, if you could tell us
in the mic a little bit about,
umm, you know, how you started
playing the piano,
what led you to
where you are today.
Eric: Test.
I come from a musical family.
I come from Camden, New Jersey.
It's near Philly, for
those of you who don't know.
Here we are.
And, uh, okay.
So, yeah.
I come from about three
to four generations
of classical musicians.
I come from, well, sadly enough,
the murder capital,
"the hood" you could say.
But I grew up in
the hood music school.
So all the old ladies and young
kids would all come and study
music under my great
grandmother and mother.
We had a very big house
in the neighborhood.
I still don't understand why in
that neighborhood
we had such a big house.
Either way, we had five pianos.
I grew up with lots of pianos
and so different classes
were being held in different
parts of the house,
in the music room, dining room, living room,
'cause there were
pianos all over the place.
So I grew up hearing Chopin,
Polonaise, stuff like that
basically.
It wasn't until about fourth
grade and I realized
everyone didn't play piano.
[laughing]
Eric: Anyway, time passes,
I get better I get better.
They turn me over to the
Southern Music School
in Philadelphia where I start
getting into, woo hoo,
we started getting into Chopin,
a etudes, and Beethoven and,
you know, the harder pieces,
and then I get exposed to jazz,
I ended up meeting Wynton
Marsalis when I was about 13.
I get enamored with the jazz,
ethos, and the lifestyle
and the look of it New York
and wanted to be there,
be a part of it.
New York, New York.
And so I ended up getting
a full scholarship
to the Manhattan School
of Music,
go there and graduate there,
graduate immediately
hit the road
with Cassandra Wilson
doing tours,
then I ended up hitting tours with Wynton Marsalis
and then John Hendricks,
and then I end up winning --
this is only a small international piano competition
in 1999.
Then I go on the road for
two years with Elvin Jones.
That was sort of my sorcerer's
apprentice,
Elvin Jones was the drummer
who supported
and co-innovated a style of
music with John Coltrane,
and so I got a up-close
and personal dosage
from a real
master of music.
Went back out with
Wynton Marsalis
after I finished that tenure,
did a little bit with
Roy Hargrove,
and then I got to a point where there was a certain kind
of power and emotion and angst
that I was looking to express
more regularly and I decided
to strike out on my own.
By the way, I spent a lot of
time with the chess hustlers
in Washington Square Park
and Greenwitch Village,
and so they kinda gave me an
idea about being more savvy
about business and stuff
like that
'cause I was losing money
from them all the time.
[laughing]
Eric: And so, uh, that was my
little free business school
and so they gave me
the idea of --
they -- they sort of created my
taste for the business world
thinking -- they got me
thinking about branding and,
you know, a lot of the things that I'm sure
you all are experts in
or very familiar with.
Niche, stuff like that.
And so took a little time
from the jazz scene
and tried to figure out
what it is I wanted to do
and then I discovered alternative rock.
I was so into the jazz world
and so into the whole concept of
being a purist and
these kinda things
that I never listened to rock
and, uh, that's
the irony of it all.
When I started hearing
some of the lyrics
some of these rock tunes
and what they conveyed,
what they expressed politically,
and also just internally I was,
like, wow, this is exactly
what I want.
And also there was a lot
of relationship
between the electric guitar
techniques and sounds
and the piano techniques
and sounds
and I decided to try to
explore that a little more
radically than had been done.
So I saw an opportunity to
integrate my niche mentality
that I got from my chess guys
and the powerful playing
that I got from Elvin Jones,
and the classical training
and stuff like that from home,
and all my world
experience in jazz
would improvising, all that.
Put it all together,
I called it rock jazz.
I play tunes that really
send me on the inside and,
uh, I think that's it.
Voila.
Presenter: And here we are.
Eric: I do movie scores
and stuff like that, too.
I got a State Farm
commercial airing right now.
Presenter: Nice.
[laughing]
Presenter: Umm, I hesitate to
ask you too much before you play
'cause then any questions
because then I feel really begs
having the listen to you
but just one quick one and we'll
let you get to the piano.
Eric: Okay.
Presenter: Umm, you know,
you add such vibrant color
to these songs that many
of us are familiar with
and you take them to
places that we really
I don't think, anybody who's
ever listened to your music
could see them going.
Umm, when you hear
the song initially,
uh, do you hear all of the color
that you could add around it?
Does it come out
of experimentation?
Is it there as soon
as you hear it?
Umm, where do you get the
inspiration for the amount
of layers that you put into
the music, or expose
how ever you see it
Eric: I'll just, uh, work my
way to some answers for that.
Right off, the lyrics,
for instance,
there's, you know,
tunes in jazz,
a lot of the jazz
standard songs --
or are regarded as standards
come from the pop repertoire
of Humphrey Bogart's time etc.
or something like
that and they have lyrics like,
"The very thought of you
makes my heart sing
like an April breeze
on the wind of spring
and you appear in
all your splendor,
my one and only love."
Lyrics like that and that's
all well and good
but I experience a lot
of emotional turmoil
in my life at certain points,
like anybody else,
it's just that as an artist to
try to pour that into music
it's difficult to take a song
that's designed to support
those kind of romantic
emotions and that -- that --
that mode of human thought or
dialogue and be appropriate,
you know, with the kind of
feelings that I get. So then,
if we turn to something
like "Lincoln Park's calling
where "I'm crawling in my skin
these wounds they will not heal fear is how I fall confusing
what is real."
Those kind of
lyrics appeal to the angst
and some of the things
that I felt
in the process of trying to come
from the strict jazz world
and get to this world.
It's the journey of discovery
that the thing I was
blowing off,
pushing to the side,
thinking, you know,
that this is lesser music
than this.
This music that I was
pushing and brushing off
held the key to my freedom.
And artistic freedom at that.
And so looking back, you know,
there are certain tunes
in this repertoire
that lyrically remind me
of that whole process.
Sometimes I felt the feelings
of betrayal.
So then, the Killer's
"Mr. Brightside" you know,
where it's all about
betrayal and, you know, that
starts to tickle my fancy.
And then there's of course,
the convergence of
the lyrics with
chord progressions and,
you know, musical elements
that are very much congruent
or ripe for the exploitation.
Presenter: Mm hmm.
Eric: Pianistically.
For instance like,
you know, in morden jazz
you know, we like McCoy Tyner,
we like Herbie Hancock
and a lot of times
that you utilize this
kind of a sound here.
♪ [plays piano chord]
Eric: You know, they take
that integral of the fifth
and just go to town with its,
you know, sounds.
These kinda sounds.
♪ [playing piano]
Eric: So, you know, it's that kind of a usage but then
something like yellow cars
lights and sounds
you know, the guitar lines
like ...
♪ [playing piano quickly]
Eric: So it's the same
kind of ethos
it's just a different
rhythmic quality.
But for me, as a piano player,
faced with a situation
where you know,
everyone's like, well,
everything's already been done.
You know, there's nothing more
to do, that typical thing.
This is one thing that hasn't
been really exploited
where we take these kind of
intervals and run around
in the left hand with
'em like a guitar player
and use them as
a support system.
To me that was being
foreshadowed by McCoy Tyner,
Elvin Jones,
Coltrane connection.
With that real extremist kind
of highly emotionalized,
extra virgin, expressionist type
of behavior or, uh, playing.
And so the alternative rock
for me was a perfect link.
'Cause most of my skills
were geared for that
that's my favorite kind of improvisational style
and so when I was turned
on to the fact that,
yeah, there's a band called Lincoln Park.
They've got tunes that are,
like, designed for you to really
bash your brains out
or bash your heart out
without anyone saying,
well, you shouldn't --
those tunes are designed.
You know, a guy screaming
in the microphone,
you know what I mean?
So for me it's like, yeah,
it's the perfect way
to take all of these techniques
that most jazz piano players
are using but take 'em to a zone
that no one's really going to.
You know, because the thing
about is that
physiologically it's difficult.
You know, this is a horizontal
plane and vertical,
but the guitar player,
you know, a 15-year-old
could take a guitar,
plug it up, turn up the volume,
and with a flick of his wrist --
[Making sound effects]
-- you know what I'm saying?
Get all that kinda good stuff,
fill up an arena.
For me to do that I gotta
come down like this.
It's like a tricep work
so I got the Gatorade here --
-- 'cause otherwise
I get cramps.
My arm will do like that.
So I had to, like,
I ended up sweating out
my salt in my body.
And so, uh, and then, of course,
you know,that's what we used to,
you know, the gyrations
and physical grimaces
and facial expressions and
stuff like that because
between the emotions of the songs trying to do justice
to the emotions of the lyrics
as well as just the sheer pain between the fingers
slamming on the keys and
my arms being set on fire
by trying to imitate
this electric guitar
tumult and beauty,
I gotta twist and turn like
an octopus, you know,
so it's that kind of a reality.
But it feels great and for me
it's a continuation of
the piano tradition
that was set up.
You know, you also have a --
like, a boogie woogie guys, too.
♪ [playing piano]
Eric: Like, they have that kinda thing going on on the left hand
so for me to cop what the guitar players are doing
is a natural relationship,
a natural progression.
And it just basically
leads to variations
that are totally interesting and
challenging, and, you know, fun.
So like a chess -- you know,
anybody who plays chess
there's like a Sicilian opening, and you know,
various openings that are
common for, you know,
Grand National tournament play
but then everyone's always
looking for some kinda
variation, some kinda new thing. Okay.
After the 25th move you go here,
this whole branch system, this whole network opens up and,
you know, this hasn't been
explored or on the flip side
this network system has been
largely explored
so it's like a whole --
it's the same thing.
But that's the same thing
that I faced in piano.
It's like, well, everybody
has pretty much
studied the records of McCoy,
Tyner, and Keith Jared,
and Herbie Hancock ,
Chick Corea,
all these type of fellows -- Bill Evans --
all these people who use
these kinda sounds
so now what do we do?
In terms of the business side
of it, in terms of branding,
you know, where do I
differentiate myself?
If I get out there and I go --
♪ [playing piano]
[high hat vocals]
Eric: Yeah. But everybody's doing it.
Everybody can do that.
So then I gotta earn, done I?
I gotta -- what do I do?
So then I gotta take the game
to the next level
and so how do I do that?
Well, that's why I listen to
"Lights and Sounds"
by Yellow Car and it's like, wow. It's the same shape.
But they're like --
[sound effects]
Why when they're doing it
on guitar it's much easier?
Well, yeah.
Well,
you know, that's why
no one's doing it on piano --
He's doing it on guitar
-- so I guess I better
learn to do it on piano.
It's gonna hurt
more but here I am.
So I guess it's working; right?
Presenter: Yep.
It certainly is.
And it's exciting
to watch you again
take on this entirely uncharted territory.
So with that, let's
hear some Eric Lewis.
[applause]
Eric: Thank you.
Shall we use this microphone
here or whose mic?
>> The one on the stand.
Eric: This one? Okay.
Eric: This next -- test --
This next--
this next one
this next one is, uh,
this first one or next one--
this first one is a --
[laughing]
Don't worry about it.
Forget about it.
I wanna play "Mr. Brightside"
by The Killers.
I said all that stuff 'cause
I gotta say all that stuff
but I just like to have a good
time, and sweat,
and pump the piano.
So that's the short
version of all this.
♪ [playing "Mr. Brightside"
on piano]
[applause]
Eric: Thank you.
Eric: Nance.
>> Yes?
Eric: You got a towel?
[woman speaking in
the background]
Presenter: It was --
Eric: No, it's not.
Eric: Pretty soon I'll be blind.
Well, anyway,
moving right along.
Thank you.
So it begins.
Presenter: This is working now.
Eric: Oh. Okay.
Great.
Ah. Angles.
My next piece I'll play for you
is a tune by a band called
"The Knife."
Wait minute.
Everybody knows that was "Mr. Brightside" by The Killers.
Mr. Brightside. Okay.
Somebody didn't know I'm sure.
This next tune is by a band
called The Knife.
It's called "Heartbeats". "Heartbeats."
♪ [playing piano strings
like guitar]
♪ [playing "Heartbeats"
on the piano]
♪ [playing piano strings
like guitar]
[abrupt ending]
[applause]
Eric: Being a piano
player's a funny thing.
Because you go from instrument
to instrument to instrument
to instrument all the time
until you're, like,
huge and then you just
take one instrument
and have crazy overweight charges on airplanes
and stuff like that,
you know what I mean?
>> Can you tell us a little bit
about your music,
about your style?
Eric: Yeah. Sure.
I'm -- I'm interactive,
you know what I mean?
So if anybody has any burning
questions, anything like that,
feel free.
But, umm, we can, you know.
I feel so odd.
It's ergonomically incorrect.
Eric: Ah. The elements
of the style.
Okay.
Well,
let's look at --
well, just now, you know,
that was hard beat so it has this line.
[playing piano]
Eric: Right?
So we can look at that as
sort of a modified ragtime
type of deal.
That's how we experience it --
experience stuff like
that in piano,
you know, that kind of counterpoint
with that kind of flavor to it.
Uh, but I'm starting
in the wrong spot.
Let me see if I can find an
efficient way to start this.
Eric: Umm ...
Eric: Well, ultimately
anything that I say
is gonna really get
back into time
pretty much as long as you
can make your deadlines
it's all good.
That's the bottom line.
So as long as, you know,
once I commit to that, bop bop bop it's like a heartbeat.
It's like that song.
Pretty much whatever you wanna
throw in there,
as long as you're making your
deadlines and keeping it clear,
pretty much it's all good.
We could get into
the semantics of it.
We can say, well,
I'm in the key of E flat or,
you know, hemiola here,
or ostinato here,
or, you know, Beethoven
did it like this.
♪ [playing piano quickly]
Eric : Like, you know,
it's -- to the human brain
this is still --
[Da da da da-ing quickly]
[Slowing down]
[tapping on piano]
[Da da da da-ing quickly
and slowing down]
Eric: -- and whatever topography
I wanna get into
or surface values.
I mean, I guess it's
just the same
as switching the order of letters on your laptop.
You know.
You know what I'm saying in
I mean, this is my approach.
I mean, people nitpick
and argue for years and write
tons of theory books and
differential equations around
and stuff like that but for me
they're just tones and colors
and this is my job.
My job is to keep this, is
to protect that consistency.
Now, whatever I need to do
to get this more colorful --
'cause obviously I can't do
a two-hour concert of,
okay hear everybody.
I want you to pay a zillion
bucks to hear me do this.
[tapping slowly on piano]
[laughing]
Eric: Isn't it great?
Pay me.
Pay me more money.
Give me more money.
[tapping slowly on piano] [laughing]
Eric: You know what I'm saying?
I can't do that.
And so that's what all --
[playing short lick on piano]
Eric: That's what all
these different colors are for;
right?
So
naturally I might be putting
a lot of music theory people
out of work or something
like that
by promoting this kind of thought but for me
I can't be thinking,
I have to you know
find this E flat or that, 'cause
I'm too busy thinking about
this song was designed --
yeah.
I keep veering -- I don't
wanna really talk like that.
So, anyway, that's
my macro soft focus.
That's my general picture
from --
from the most zoomed out perspective,
the most user-friendly
perspective.
[tapping foot slowly on stage]
Eric: Keep this.
You know, when I was playing
with Elvin Jones and Wynton Marsalis or whatever, you know,
and they're experimenting
doing different things,
my job as the piano player
is to stay out of the way
and keep the beat clear
so that they don't have to
focus so hard on
where is the time?
One, two, three, four.
You know, the division
of the time.
They don't have to focus on that
because it's so present
that they can focus in
on ornamentation,
and embellishment,
and enhancement,
'cause that's the idea of taking
this -- this thing here
and embellishing it
with these instruments into
various sounds so that,
you know, it's lovely for the human experience.
It's still basically an
ergonomic approach to --
[tapping slowly on piano]
Eric: Everything -- you know,
if we spiral downwards you know
we get into -- we get into okay. Here's C. [playing piano]
Eric: Here's D.
Here's D flat.
You wanna call it an eighth
note,
you wanna call it a 16th note feel free, you know,
But I can't think like that.
I mean, that doesn't
serve me especially
when I'm playing tunes by bands
who they're not really
designing those tunes
based upon those kind of principals.
They're not trying to say,
hey everybody, I wanna sell
seven million records but I want you to realize is that
I'm in the Aeolian mode
of B minor, okay.
You look at the liner notes
of, like, you know,
Thursday's record or something like that. It's like, okay.
This record was designed for
you to really understand
that I want you to, uh,
appreciate the hemiola that
I was playing in bar five of,
you know, my
lead singer was screaming.
Yes, that was designed to use
a cathartic experience
or to further exemplify
that cathartic experience,
you know, we had --
a Dorian mode executed here. [laughing]
I mean, cause-- that's timely.
It consumes a lot of time,
you know what I'm saying?
And that's fine once again
it's all what's your pleasure?
What's your pleasure?
Double your pleasure,
double your fun.
You know, I mean,
whatever you're into.
But as far as what I'm into,
I'm happy to do something like.
♪ [playing piano darkly]
If that sounds like
a thunderstorm,
you know what I'm saying.
But if, you know, someone's
mortified that I did that
it's like, well,
I'm playing a song
that's supposed to
be about tumult
and this sounds like
an airplane to me.
♪[playing piano darkly]
Ah, not that part, but --
♪ [playing piano darkly]
I mean, we hear that kind of stuff in movie scores.
We have computer effects that
generate those kinda sounds.
So basically I'm just
an environmentalist.
I try to make what I'm doing
match the sound,
the human beings of my time and
culture are used to hearing.
And, uh, I guess it sounds
pretty evasive
when I'm talking about,
you know, I'm not getting into,
well --
Maybe I should go another way.
Well, yeah. I guess I said enough about that
why don't I go into some more mechanical stuff. Okay.
Stuff like, uh --
♪ [playing piano]
Eric: [da da da-ing]
[da da da-ing]
Eric: What's the difference
between that and --
♪ [playing piano]
Eric: For me the differences
are purely semantic.
You know, ragtime was imitating
the John Phillip Sousa concept
and the Scott Joplin turned
it around this and that.
But Lynard Skynard was,
you know,
approaching the eighth note another kind of --
that's just not my personality anymore at least. You know.
Uh, it might --
did that help? Did I.
[laughing]
Eric: Did I get anything?
Did I make any sense?
You feel good?
Does everybody feel good?
Eric: Okay. Cool.
Yes.
Ah. Okay.
Here's one.
Mahara fan.
Mahara movie fan.
Here's a tune
that I'm going to play some
horror effects inside the piano.
I'm gonna --
I'm talking crazy.
My sense of structure's all off.
I'm so nervous I'm, like,
shooting ahead of myself.
Eric: Which tone?
Okay. Evanessence is going under.
This is the tune that I
played at the TED Conference.
Interestingly enough,
I had a meeting with
Clyde Barker a couple days ago
because his agent happened
to be at the TED Conference
when I did all these kind of
effects and stuff like that
and so now he and I are
gonna be collaborating
so I'm really excited about that.
I took a lot of flak for
going inside the piano.
I was so surprised.
This is, like,
monoclassical music.
What's the big deal?
But, uh, it worked out.
I'm bragging.
I feel good about that.
[laughing]
Eric: For all of you
who called me insane.
Hah. [laughing]
[tapping quickly on piano]
[playing short piano chord]
[playing lightly on piano
strings]
♪ [playing piano]
[applause]
Eric: Thank -- thank you. [applause]
That was -- that was Yellow
Cards' Lights and Sounds.
And, uh, let's see.
What do you think?
Oh. Here's one.
I'll play a little, uh --
here's a little jazzy thing. This is called "Medicine Man."
This is for a good buddy
of mine.
I'll try it out on you guys.
I haven't even really
performed this one.
"Medicine Man."
♪ [playing piano quickly
and lightly]
[applause]
Eric: Yeah. Yeah.
No problem.
Oh. Okay.
That's all right.
Uh, okay.
Here's a tune by a band
known as Breaking Benjamin.
It's called "The Diary of Jane."
♪ [playing piano]
[applause]
Presenter: Eric Lewis, everyone.
[applause, cheering]
Presenter: So, I wanted
to give him
I wanted to give him as much
playing time as possible
so unfortunately I don't think
we have time for questions
for the you tube video
but I'm sure you'd be willing to
stick around for a few minutes.
We're gonna be having
lunch afterwards
so if you have questions,
umm, feel free to ask.
But I think we're
done with the video.
[applause]